[Applause]
some here oppose vaccine mandates others
oppose masks some oppose their
government entirely together they've
brought this border crossing to a
complete standstill
the busiest land link between the usa
and canada now a hockey pitch
right now we're hitting the elites right
where it hurts and this will stop it you
think they're listening you think justin
trudeau is listening they have no choice
but to listen they're losing money and
that's what elites don't like is losing
money i have five children
and when they misbehave
i put them on timeout
to
change things and i think this is time
out for the government do you feel sorry
for people who this is affected
yeah in a way i do but at the same time
i think uh the time that we're spending
out here is very little compared to the
time that we've all been cooped up in
our homes this is an absolutely vital
trade route between the usa and canada
and it's now been shut for three days
fears growing understandably for the
supply chains of the businesses who rely
on this room people's jobs people's
livelihoods and businesses in peril
this area on both sides of the border
relies on just-in-time deliveries for
car factories if this bridge remains
empty much longer they may grind to a
halt and the authorities are at a loss
for how to deal with the demonstrators
the problem that you see is they're
hardened in their position
but many there have also expressed that
this is a cause that they're willing to
die for
and so that elevates the psyche on the
ground to a whole different level where
police need a
different type of response because we
don't want anyone to get hurt
copycat blockades have sprung up at
other cities and border crossings the
economic impact is untold even if their
message is confused these protesters
know that this has made them impossible
to ignore